I am Elizabeth cinnamon our staff I am
an artist and a member of the l's is
a committee it is my great play
to introduce our distinguished speakers
today at Yale for this wonderful event
the art of nature in the nature of art
exploring the reunion of Arts and
biodiversity sciences today we hope to
explore the connection between two areas
of human inquiry that arise in the same
source the desire the wish to make sense
of and understand the world around us
but these two have drifted apart so much
so that their individual vocabularies
have become nearly foreign to one
another this symposium arose from a
desire to reintegrate and reinvigorate
art and science our speakers come from a
variety of disciplines we have with us
artists art historians biologists but
all of these have a shared love of both
art and science and the wellspring that
inspires us to be inquisitive which is
nature our first speakers are Amy Myers
and Robert peck Amy Myers director of
the Yale Center British art has written
extensively about Natural History and
art her books include mark Kate's B's
new world vision and the recently
released knowing about me knowing nature
wonderful wonderful book it's art in
science in Philadelphia 1742 1840 a
project she began as curator of American
Art at Huntington Library in California
and continued at Yale is a truly
beautiful book Robert Peck is a curator
of arts and artifacts and senior fellow
at the addo me of Natural Sciences in
Philadelphia he is a writer naturalist
historian and world traveler Bob
recently published a monumental book on
the history of the Academy of Natural
Science I hope to be like a dad
everybody was amazing book again it is a
celebration of the Academy's 200th
anniversary he is currently working on a
book and exhibition about the parrot
paintings of Edward Lear please welcome
just give me a moment
this one
thank you so much Liz and may I just say
that as the director of another unit at
Yale I am so delighted to be part of
this program today I should note just
before I begin that I did my doctoral
work here at Yale many many decades ago
as an American Studies PhD and really
it's out of that work too many years ago
that I can say that this project about
which I'll say just a few words today
began but I couldn't have imagined a
center like this which would bring us
all together in the extraordinary way
that you are and I hope that this
presages a really remarkable set of
cross-disciplinary discussions I think
that this center in the center for the
Frankie center for science and the
humanities at Yale are natural partners
but we at the Yale Center for British
art hope that we'll be able to partner
with you as well on many projects into
the future so thank you for including me
and thank you for your kind words with
over the course of the 18th century the
relatively open and permissive
intellectual society of quaker
philadelphia the largest and wealthiest
metropolis of the british colonies in
the transatlantic world fostered an
especially keen receptiveness to the new
science and as the sociologist Digby
bald cell has written brought the
Enlightenment to America I hope they're
no Bostonians sitting on the side
the culture of science that developed in
this major intellectual hub of the
colonial world and that extended
ultimately into the 19th century and
beyond is the focus of the two books
that Bob Peck and I have edited recently
in Bob's case a glorious enterprise the
academy of natural sciences of
philadelphia and the making of american
science the magnificent publication
accompanying a rich series of
exhibitions and programs celebrating the
Academy's 200th anniversary mounted over
the course of this year and a mine
knowing nature art and science and
philadelphia 1742 1840 a set of 14
essays by a range of distinguished art
historians social and political
historians and historians of science
that offer a dynamic picture of how the
visual and material interpretation of
the natural world functioned not only
income in colonial and early republican
science but across the culture of the
period more generally as close collegial
friends bob and i have been working
together on these topics for over 4 30
years i met bob when i was working on my
dissertation here so that was a long
time ago indeed bob authored an essay in
my book and so we are delighted indeed
honored to introduce you to our related
projects together this afternoon I will
begin our joint presentation with a
brief overview of the wide-ranging
subjects covered in knowing nature after
which Bob will discuss his own
publication and the Academy programs to
which it speaks the essays that comprise
knowing nature elucidate a multiplicity
of ways in which a pervasive interest in
nature fostered in Philadelphia for
spiritual aesthetic economic and
political ends affected those processes
of making traditionally associated with
scientific practice of the day such as
the crafting of cabinets of curiosity
menagerie Zatanna gardens and images of
natural productions and of the limitless
examples I might have chosen I show you
here a drawing of the garden of the
botanist John
Bartram my his son William in which was
executed in 1758 and played 35 and
volume 4 of Alexander Wilson's American
ornithology or the natural history of
birds in the United States published in
Philadelphia between 1808 and 9 and 18
14 a radical scottish weaver who
emigrated to north america and supported
himself as a schoolteacher wilson was
mentored as a naturalist artist by
william Bartram in the family's garden i
was encouraged by william to produce the
first illustrated book on North American
birds to be published on this continent
and I know the subject is deeply
meaningful to us here at Yale so I
thought that you might want to see what
those first images might have looked
like while examining the plethora of
materials produced directly in
conversation with science indeed often
self-consciously in its service knowing
nature also charts those activities not
ordinarily linked to scientific practice
that involved the close study of nature
from the design and production of
textiles and garments decorative arts
objects domestic and institutional
interiors and architectural structures
to the mapping of land and the reshaping
of its contours through agricultural
production and again of the infinite
numbers of objects and images that might
be shown as examples I show you here
objects that resulted from such close
observations of the natural world one of
the first pieces of American soft
porcelain pastry a pickle stand
decorated with small shells cast from
real mollusks by goose Bonham and
Anthony George Anthony Morris in
Philadelphia in the first years of the
1770s we can't date the stand exactly
but these little shells that you see
along the stem were actually collected
studied and then cast as part of the
larger image which would have connoted
hospitality and generosity in the form
of the scallop shells which then have an
iconographic importance and also a bed
cover from about 1,800
made from floral fabrics that were based
on studies of the natural world birds
and flowers that were blocked printed by
the fabric producer John Hewson an
astute study of nature in his own right
the often surprisingly intimate
connections between an among those
observing nature directly in the service
of science and those doing so for other
ends are examined closely through the
essays in this book calling into
question the hierarchy that is generally
assumed to have been a play in the study
of the natural world from the Natural
Sciences through the fine and decorative
arts and ultimately through popular and
material culture indeed the many ways in
which the process of coming to know
nature was essentially reversed in which
artistic and artisanal culture informed
scientific interpretations of the
natural world might be considered a
central theme of the book the general
supposition that science was the
province of gentlemen alone is also
challenged and how artists and
craftspeople with their special
knowledge of natural materials came into
conversation with those investigating
nature for theoretical and practical
purposes of science is explored for many
vantage points on the screen for example
you see an image of the exclamation of
the mastodon painted between 1806 and
1808 by the Philadelphia artist and
museum director Charles Willson Peale to
him the Peabody of courses a great debt
to celebrate the success of the
partially mechanized system that Peale
developed to extract from the grounds of
a farm in shawwal gunk New York the
bones of three mastodons from which he
would construct the first complete
skeleton of the beach ever assembled
pele shows in this work the entire range
of workers invested in this heroic
challenge from the day laborers
operating the machine and extracting the
bones from the pit through family
members and scientific colleagues
helping him to direct the process
and to conceptualize the skeleton
through the art of drying and you can
see peel holding his great trying that
symbolically attaches to of the bones
through which she's worked out this
process that's held up by various family
members who are part of his team so to
speak so this is very much about
communal and cross-disciplinary
enterprise which involves a vast array
of people and their professions not
simply Academy trained scientists and
it's just of course at the time when
specialization is emerging in
Philadelphia is becoming a real center
of supplies science but peel won't let
you forget that that science can't be
done without a very intimately linked
and vast array of specialists each in
their own right contributing to the
process in short knowing nature presents
a group of case studies that upset the
traditional hierarchical view of the
production of knowledge which dictates
that science informs art a hierarchical
view that is hindered a clear
understanding of how analytical
approaches to the natural world
developed during the eighteenth and
early nineteenth centuries in so doing
these case studies place central
importance on creative processes and
object types not usually considered as
relevant to the history of science at
the same time these examinations also
explore the ways in which those creative
processes and object types which
customarily have been associated
exclusively with scientific practice
actually functioned in many cultural
arenas you're looking at my favorite
growing focused analyses illustrate for
example that objects which naturally
seem to have crafted solely for the
purposes of science often served as
social commentary or autobiographical
reflection evidencing both the
self-conscious interest taken by natural
who made them in the overlapping
communities of which they were apart and
their own roles in these various spheres
and I show you here a particularly
powerful instance of this a botanical
drawing by William Bartram made in 1796
to illustrate one of his new discoveries
from the New Jersey side of the Delaware
River and orchid he called arethusa
devar kata yet the image is far more
than a scientific illustration intended
to define the attributes of the species
and you can see that's very tall orchid
which he causes to stretch across the
whole of the paper vertically but
there's so much more that's going on in
this image along with the date of the
drawing and his signature of artist
Bartram inscribed his venerable age than
of 56 years old explicitly marking the
moment when he portrayed his new find in
the history of his own career indeed he
shows the specimen as growing from a
great piece of turf including other
notable discoveries from across much of
that distinguished career going back to
the tippity widget or the Venus flytrap
of which he made the first drawing while
visiting his uncle on the Cape Fear
River in North Carolina from 1761 to
1762 and if you look at the base of the
Arethusa just run your eye down you'll
see a sundew at the very bottom and just
your eye travels left and you'll see the
Venus flytrap with its open trap on the
very far left-hand bottom part of the
drawing that drawing the one that he
made in the 1760s to illustrate the
tippity widget and the seeds and
specimens he collected had been sent by
his father John to his English
colleagues among whom the plant
described by Linnaeus as miraculum
natori would cause a sensation now many
decades later in his drawing of arethusa
from the late 1790s William poses the
specimen and its forebears
in his pantheon of plant discoveries
against the city of Philadelphia which
had matured into a major international
national propolis and tandem with the
growth of the bartram zone garden
creating an autobiographical work that
meshes the history of the city into
which he and his family were inscribed
so significantly as naturalist's indeed
as many of the essays that constitute
knowing nature demonstrate during this
critical period of the development of
North American science as the United
States emerged as a young Republic many
Philadelphia naturalist's as members of
the leading scientific community of the
transatlantic world thought seriously
about their communal ties locally
regionally and internationally taking
into consideration a complex of major
factors a real matrix including national
origin ethnicity race gender regional at
political affiliation religion economic
interests and class and meshing these
into their analysis of the national the
natural world such considerations
surface frequently in their work helping
us to understand how these early
investigators bound themselves to some
communities and distinguish themselves
from others created a creating a
complicated indeed kaleidoscopic world
of complimentary and competing interests
in the natural productions of North
America these meditations on
self-definition and communal affiliation
form a critical strand that runs through
the essays that constitute knowing
nature charting a century of monumental
changes during which time Philadelphia
shifted in status from the largest and
most affluent colonial city of British
North America and of the British Empire
of course to the capital of the New
Republic and finally to one of several
competing centers of political social
and cultural influence these
examinations demonstrate how the study
of the material and artistic culture of
science can illuminate much broader
attitudes and trends indeed neither as
definitive nor is comprehensive this
collection of essays points the way to
further cross-disciplinary studies in
which objects made to promote an
understanding of nature can be seen to
reflect the aspirations and anxieties
the successes and failures of the larger
cultures of which they were apart and of
course we will hope that this Center and
those across galva unite this
cross-disciplinary pursuit will help us
forward in our understanding of this
complex intellectual matrix that begins
to be discussed in this book by way of
reflection I leave you here with an
image of Charles Willson Peale I'm
standing in his great Museum as he
depicted himself in 1822 thinking hard
about his role and the many communities
of which he of course was a part as well
as those to whom he would introduce
these communities through the museum as
a site of learning and we of course have
several of those major sites of light
kinds at Yale the Peabody being first
and foremost Bob will say a few more
words about this image as he talks about
the academy of natural sciences so I'm
delighted hand over the podium thank you